I have procured you a spot on Dancing
with the Stars grocery store Joe on
Dancing with the Stars this is fun
good time with this one yeah happy about
this this is gonna be great don't know
how to dance
no to do this a bit of have I'm actually
having a panic attack right now if you
can't tell so it's great it's gonna go
to go really well super excited oh boy I
like I didn't even dancing in 8th Grade
I danced like I didn't you didn't even
do the like the grind nothing not a
dancer do you watch the show who would
you want your partner to be I have to
I'm gonna have to do some research it's
not like I need the best one they got to
give me the best one give me any move it
you have I don't I don't have Eddie so
that's gonna be a problem
well how does it feel for you I mean
you're this guy this is this crazy story
from night one only you skyrocketed to
fame they aren't Dancing with the Stars
is that wild to you yes yes Dancing with
the Stars is the craziest thing that's
ever happened to me up to date right now
how is it gonna be for you to get to
live with Kendall in LA that's gonna be
awesome I don't know if we're gonna jump
into that right away but we'll be close
to each other so I'd help you with
somewhere hurt someone
yeah that's for sure well what do you
see as what's next for you - where do
you guys want to go from here um I think
we're just gonna take it stride by
stride right and see where I think being
in LA now is gonna be a big help for
that
and I know we're making progress it's
going good
you
[Music]